professor mends each in your book lost
decades the making of America's debt
crisis and the long recovery how big is
the US debt and who owns it what do we
mean by own well the u.s. debt is things
like 14 trillion dollars and it's maybe
in terms of publicly held debt about 70
percent of GDP so if that's how giving
you some perspective it tells you that
you know it's an unprecedented amount at
least in post-war history now who is it
ode to I'd say you know most of it is
owed to other Americans and so in some
sense you can think about it as we're
borrowing from ourselves a sizable chunk
is owed to foreigners of which if you
wanted to you know this being candidates
it would be the the Chinese and you know
various oil exporters what how do you
how do you quantify debt what what is
considered US debt well that's a
complicated question I mean there's most
of the numbers you hear our debt that's
owed by the US government and so that's
the actually the number I threw out but
there's a lot of other debt including
debt by households to banks corporations
to other corporations into financial
institutions and so you know if I were
to add up all that debt it would be sort
of double counting and in fact most of
the time as economists we talk about the
net debt so what's the our net debt to
the rest of the world in terms of all
private individuals and the government
and that works out to something like at
the moment 25 percent of GDP now that's
a lot but we probably in and of itself
it's not as problematic as certain times
the question is not net debt you know
netting out what the corporation's owe
each other but the fact that certain
times some corporations and some
households get into trouble and they're
unable to pay their debt and they become
insolvent and so that ripples through
the economy and you can't just say oh
there's a dollar of debt here but it's o
to another person over here and that
sort of all washes out it's those times
that lead to crises when instead
tuitions and households had counted on
having assets
they'd loan money to somebody and they
can't get it back and corporations or
firms have borrowed money and they can't
pay it back and that results in a real
debt crisis let's talk about public debt
when you talk about the 14 trillion is
that correct of public debt
does that include future Social Security
Medicare payments things like that no it
doesn't it includes just that
outstanding amount of Treasuries that
are out there and in in general what I'm
gonna do is sort of net out what's owed
between accounts within the US or the
federal government so it's really just
what's the the debt that's outstanding
that's being held by the public
professor chin what is a Treasury a
Treasury is a is a security or liability
of the federal government that's
directly issued by the US Treasury so
borrowed by the federal government do
you own Treasuries do I own Treasuries
we know if we got if we're invested in
pension fund anything like that
we're indirectly owning Treasuries it's
likely that the whole certain amount of
government Treasuries I don't I think
have anything typically we don't unless
you know you have it in some IRA that's
invested in some other fund maybe you
know a savings bond would be the closest
thing that a lot of us would have seen
the University of Wisconsin does it hold
Treasuries lots of good question I
actually don't know probably not not the
university itself but the sort of
retirement system that is that its
employees are invested in all right we
say that the Chinese are buying our debt
what does that mean how does that
operate well the way to think about it
is the Chinese for a long time
were exporting a lot lot more than they
were importing and they would as a
country earn proceeds and most of it was
in the form of dollars okay so they
exported a lot of stuff to the rest of
the world most of the goods they sell
are invoiced in dollars so they get
receipts in dollars and the question
then is if they're earning a lot more
from their exports than they're spending
on imported goods
then they're gonna have a pile of
foreign-exchange accumulating and you
could keep it in currency but you know
currency gets you zero interest and it's
in practical you know so so what they do
is typically it's held in the form of
Treasuries so when you say or you hear
somebody say that the Chinese hold lots
of Treasuries or they have big dollar
reserves essentially they're saying that
they're holding no dollar assets mostly
in the form of Treasuries because
Treasuries are in some ways the safest
asset in the world you know we haven't
defaulted for a long stretch of time on
on Treasuries the US government and
they're easy to get in and out of the
that is they're highly liquid so in some
sense it's the ideal form in which to
save it and that's why the Chinese and
many oil exporters like Saudi Arabia and
Kuwait wouldn't have their foreign
exchange reserves in the form of
Treasuries as an economist is that a bad
thing for the US I don't think it's
necessarily a bad thing that China holds
them I think it would be a bad thing if
we kept on having the rest of the world
accumulate Treasuries at a rapid pace
because what it means as the US
government is accumulating debt at a
rapid pace now those things those
processes that were under way for a good
chunk of time during the 2000s and even
back into the 1990s they're they're
slowing down so one of the big
earth-shaking things that you don't hear
about very much right now is that China
is actually running down its pile of
foreign exchange reserves that is a
sharp sharp sharp break with what has
happened over the past 15 years and so
we are getting in some sense what we
wanted that the US government is you
know as a share of GDP and as a share of
world GDP accumulating data the less
rapid pace
but it's also the case where the rest of
the world isn't buying as many
Treasuries as it used to and that over
time has ramifications for the interest
rates we pay you know if they're buying
less of our Treasuries then relative to
anything else the price of Treasuries
will be lower and that's the same as
higher interest rates okay so there are
many offsetting effects going on at the
same time but that's the tendency if
emerging market countries are including
China
and oil exporters tend to accumulate
fewer Treasuries then that's going to
put upward pressure on interest rates
and that's that too has been a change
over the past eight years where interest
rates have including interest rates on
US government debt have been unnaturally
low well the title of your book is lost
decades what happened in 2008 that and
how is that rippled well that's a great
question and I think the the key idea
that Jeffrey Frieden my co-author and I
wanted put forward is that through all
this welter of you know acronyms like
CDSs and CDOs and mortgage backed
securities and all these other terms
that were flying around there's
basically a one single underlying story
that has actually been repeated over and
over again throughout history and that
is that for whatever reasons governments
either encourage or on their own
push through increased borrowing
sometimes it's in the belief that the
times are different and we can manage
that increased borrowing in an efficient
way and a safe way so Alan Greenspan
some time in the mid 2000 said well
we're we're all borrowing much more but
we're in essence a lot smarter than we
used to be we have computer we have
computers to to manage risk we have new
theories about how to deal with risk we
have new derivatives that can help us
manage risk and so the idea that we
could just borrow more is not as scary
as it used to be and I think our view is
that's a very dangerous idea and it's a
particularly dangerous idea because we
get into trouble exactly when we
borrowed a lot and then the environment
changes and a lot of the borrowing that
looked like it was going to be repaid
easily isn't and that's essentially 2008
it's the the household borrowed up to
the hilt because they thought well
housing prices would keep on going up so
it makes sense to borrow the bank's
loaned and they also borrowed financial
institutions borrowed and they were
partly able to evade regulations because
the regulations were outdated with
back to you know how much you had to
hold in reserve as capital so you had a
combination of financial deregulation
that's the sort of direct government
interventions you had the government
itself embarking on a spending spree
after the 2001 tax cuts we cut taxes get
in 2003 and that encouraged more
borrowing and we had financial
innovation and all these three things
led to increase in borrowing by all
sectors of the economy and it all worked
fantastically to give us this period of
prosperity until of course it didn't
work that is people said oh let's
reassess whether housing prices will
keep on going up oh those securities
that we issued well I don't think
they're worth quite as much as we
thought or the regulators thought and
the whole system starts unraveling in
Reverse the political response to 2008
Ben Bernanke Henry Paulson Sheila Bair
Presidents Bush and Obama did they get
it right I think once the crisis
unfolded definitely Ben Bernanke and the
Federal Reserve acted correctly and
that's no smart small measure in do to
the part that Bernanke's doctoral theses
had to do with the Great Depression and
the fact that you know he worked out a
new interpretation of why the Great
Depression was so severe and that was
because the collapse of banking sector
and this view was slightly actually a
big departure from the dominant view
that was associated with Milton Friedman
which had talked about the monetary
influences Bernanke talked about the
credit influences said you really have
to rescue the financial system to make
sure that lending continues and so I
gave him a lot of credit for saving
things the Bush administration did push
through a small stimulus package in 2008
and that probably helped a bit but
really in terms of fiscal policy tarp
which was the bank bailout was
incredibly important because it
reassured people in the financial sector
along with the Federal Reserve actions
shirred people that the banking system
was going to continue okay essentially
tarp was a recapitalization of the
banking system the banks had been
holding lots of assets that suddenly
were less valuable than they originally
thought if that happened sufficiently
then the banks are insolvent and they
either shut down or the continuous like
zombie banks as they did in Japan for a
while and so you need somebody to come
in to provide funds to make those banks
solvent and that's what the US
government did if it hadn't then I would
think that you know the financial system
would have ground to a halt eventually
it would not immediately but it would
have stopped lending and you can't run
in finance you can't run an economy
actually without a financial system
that's working
professor Qin our recessions and
economic downturns natural occurrences I
think they're natural occurrences
because you are always going to have a
confluence of events that that strike
economies that we're going to push them
down or up and so cycles are going to
occur you don't want to think them as
sort of mechanical so you at the moment
you hear about people saying this
recovery is unnaturally long it's longer
than the average and so it must by
definition come to an end my view would
be at some time you know either the
Federal Reserve acts in a way that tips
the economy into recession or some shock
strikes that forces the feds hands or
some shock combination of shocks from
overseas just induces the economy to tip
into a negative growth pattern and so
the big question now I guess there are
two big questions one is you know what
will the Federal Reserve do and will it
be able to manage that just slow the
economy down that's their objective it's
never to just throw the economy into
recession the other question is if the
Federal Reserve is not the thing that
precipitates Moving's recession is it
the combination of world events and that
would be a new event most the time I
think we think about the United States
is moving along on its own path and not
being driven by external influences if
this is a new case where China
and China's slowdown precipitates a
greater slowdown in the East Asian
region which then is transmitted to the
US that would be a new configuration the
world economy was the legislative
response in the last since 2008 has it
been effective some of the new
restrictions some of the new laws that
have been put in place are they
important for stabilization of economy
so I think that they're there many fold
aspects of the legislative response and
no the first one the first big one was
the ARRA the American Recovery and
Reinvestment Act which was implemented
in 2009 and that was a big
counter-cyclical move that is it as the
economy was going down there was upward
movement from that stimulus and I'd say
that was one of the most important
things to to push the economy in the
right direction otherwise we could be
mired in a much longer recession okay
that was early on and most of the
effects of that have petered out but I
think that mitigated a lot of the the
the pain and suffering that could have
occurred now the other innovations or
legislation that was passed I think have
more long lasting implications and that
includes the dodd-frank legislation
regarding banking regulation and so
that's really important over the longer
term in so far as it really it it
reduces the incentives for banks to over
leveraged that is to borrow up in large
amounts only putting in a little little
bit of their own shareholders money and
borrow up using a sort of short-term
financial market instruments which those
are the two sort of things that got the
financial system into trouble before and
I think with implementation of
dodd-frank and sort of international
regulations on banking so what are
called on the rubric of Basel three that
you've actually made the banking system
a lot more stable there still remains
some holes in the regulation of the
international
system and I'd say that it's now one of
the things is we fix problems in the
sectors where we've seen the problems
it's likely that the next problem we see
is someplace that we didn't expect it or
we didn't apply regulations I mean one
way of thinking about 2008 is you know
it wasn't the the mainline banks that
were the big problem we regulated them
in 1930s in response to the problems of
the Great Depression
but then we encountered a whole set of
problems in the shadow financial system
because individuals and firms and banks
and other financial institutions had
worked their way around those
regulations or you know here's the term
of financial innovation they had
innovated the way around the regulations
and so we put in the whole set of
regulations now I think it's made the
system safer for a period of time more
robust more stable but people are always
going to be looking around for a way of
evading the regulations so that they can
get a higher rate of return and at the
same time impose the risks upon the
greater financial system and that's that
the hazard that regulators keep on
having to try to keep up with those who
are trying to evade the regulations is
that the message you want people who
read lost the lost decades to take away
the lessons that's exactly one of them
it's that you can't just say we've had
this one big crisis we fix things now
move on history is replete with these
examples where individuals households
firms banks whatever all want to
leverage up because that's a way of
making higher return than you would
otherwise and they want to leverage up
borrow a lot and there's a tendency
because it induces a at least in the
short term a period of buoyant growth
and returns
there's always incentive to say well
there's no trouble there's no problem at
the point at this point if I'm a
politician it's going to land into
somebody else's lap in the future if I'm
a household you might say I'll get out
just before everything crashes or
there's a tendency to say times are
different now
we're just smarter or more nimble than
we used to be the old rules don't apply
and I think our main point is the old
rules to large extent do still apply if
you try to borrow a lot leverage up a
lot then inevitably some correction will
come round and a lot of pain is going to
be inflicted upon a lot of and many
times innocent bystanders what are you
teaching here at the University of
Wisconsin and what do you want your
students after a semester with you to
leave with so I teach mostly
macroeconomics so international
macroeconomics to both undergraduates in
the Economics Department and I teach
sort of an international macro course
two masters level students in the
LaFollette School of Public Affairs and
the the one thing that I want them to
know is keep alert to read about what's
going on in the world and incorporate
what you've learned in class to
analyzing why is it that you know things
are the way they are why is it that
certain individuals in certain positions
of management in financial firms say
what they say versus what people in
policy positions would say versus what
journalists would say in particular to
use their minds to analyze and dissect
what's being stated and argued rather
than taking for granted you know
somebody says something and because they
look authoritative believe it I want
them to question question everything and
to use their minds to analyze what's
going around going on around them all
right macroeconomics why can a small
country like Greece mm-hmm affect our
giant economy here in the US
so that's interesting question and it is
let me give you an analogue there was a
interesting statement about that the
construction market or construction in
the u.s. leading up to 2008 people would
say well construction of housing only
counts for a small portion of GDP how
can it affect the rest of the economy
and I think what we've learned over the
past eight nine years is
interconnections matter and in in
particular in the case of housing it
wasn't just the actual act of building
housing but it was the fact that people
owned assets that were involved in
housing or houses and that assets were
derived or derivatives had their value
on the basis of housing prices in the
case of Greece lots of private
individuals and had assets that were
issued by the Greek government or issued
by Greece private individuals and so
those holdings lose value as you think
that they're less able to pay and so
there's a big ramification for people's
portfolios their perceptions of net
wealth that's one instance I'd say in
the case of Greece there was another set
of concerns and one of which is that the
euro was built upon the concept that no
government could default that every
government was going to be embarked upon
a path of sustainable finances okay so
the very fact that a country within the
euro area would get into trouble and
then would have to be bailed out which
is against you know that that's written
out of the the Charter for the eurozone
so that sort of forced a reassessment of
what is possible and if you think about
it it's not just Greece it's a Greece
signals what could happen to the other
periphery countries so Portugal Italy
Ireland Spain you know those other
countries also had problems with their
finances and it's not just Greece going
out but the signal
that Greece gives about whether those
countries could also face a similar
problem have to be bailed out and what
that means for the sustainability of the
the single European currency and you're
watching book TV on c-span - and we've
been talking with University of
Wisconsin professor Minzy Jim he's the
co-author of this book lost decades the
making of America's debt crisis and long
recovery Thank You professor thank you